We start off with an input for vertex cover then apply pre-processing
using the rule that we just discovered, which means we then already know that this vertex here
must be put into the vertex cover as well as this one here and this one here
and these all do not have to be in the vertex cover and this of course is
dramatically effective in this case here.
It's unfortunately not always the case in practice but as you can see it only leaves a very small part
of the network actually where we have to find an assignment but the main point is that
we now put this into a search tree to find the best possible vertex cover for those vertices
where we have not yet found an assignment.
And now my point is this, the search tree that we had so far was as follows.
We started out by looking at an uncovered edge and then we branch into three possibilities.
We either put exactly one of the vertices into the vertex cover or both.
And now comes the cool part, if we have applied pre-processing then we can redesign
our search tree because what this pre-processing step means basically is that we have eliminated
or we have already assigned all vertices now to have just a single neighbor.
Now that we have applied pre-processing, we know a little bit more about these vertices here
because we know that this vertex here will have at least one more neighbor
because otherwise we would have already found it in the pre-processing
and this one here will also have another neighbor.
There can be more. The same thing here.
What we can now do is we can do a more sophisticated search tree
and that sophisticated search tree is going to be based on this part here, these three vertices.
You can do more sophisticated search trees but I just want to show you the basic principle here.